>>
Hi, were here today at Google I/O to talk
to Jay and, Jay, do you mind introducing yourself
and talk a little bit about your company?
>> HINDMAN: No problem. I’m HINDMAN, I’m
the senior director of Partner and Product
Marketing at MobiTV. And MobiTV--we’re relatively
new to Android development and we’re kind
of showcasing some of our applications at
the show right now. Our core product is MobiTV,
and that’s 40 live or made from mobile channels
from big brands like ESPN, ABC, CBS, NBC,
Discovery, et cetera. And that’s been available
for a long time on different platforms and
is now being ported over to Android which
we’re really excited about. MobiForBiz is
another new product that we’ve come out
with that allows you to get personalized breaking
video alerts on stocks that you happened to
be--to own in your portfolio, as well as watch
live business TV on CNBC, Bloomberg and others.
>> Okay, that’s great. So, you mentioned
being kind of new to Android. What is it about
Android that got you to put your application
to it and make it available on the (INDISTINCT)
>> HINDMAN: Yeah, I mean, it’s two things.
First of all, our development team was very
excited when Android was announced. The fact
that they knew it was going to be very open
sourced and that they’d have the ability
to kind of get into the code and do a lot
of things that they maybe are unable to do
other platforms. But also, we generally let
our carriers’ handset roadmap kind of dictate
which handsets work to and we’re very close
with AT&T, Sprint and others knowing that
they got Android devices on the horizon meant
that we were going to be developing our preloaded
applications on those, anyway.
>> Okay, great. You know, one thing developers
really like to hear is more stories, stories
going to entrance us, do you have anything
you could share with us?
>> HINDMAN: Yeah. Yeah, I talked to our development
team a little bit about this. So, we have
a product called MObiVJ that we’re also
making available for Android. The MobiVJ is
roughly 18 channels and music videos, but
also a whole bunch of audio-only channels
or radio channels from different genres of
music. And one of the things that they noticed
as they started developing this product is
that the way the Android widget for video
playback works is that when you try to play
an audio-only clip, it’s actually looking
for video. So in a hybrid product like this
that’s both audio and video, it’s looking
for video to display on the screen. If it
doesn’t, it won’t even play the audio
feed. So, what they did is they invented a
single pixel and then painted over it, a single
video pixel, so when you start that audio
stream, it pulls up the video pixel and says,
“Oop, yup, it’s definitely a video, it’s
playing,” and then it goes ahead and plays
the audio stream. And if it happens to be
video that’s playing, it just goes full
screen and plays the whole--the whole video
clip.
>> Okay, that’s great.
>> HINDMAN: Yeah.
>> Are there other things about the tool chain
or the development process that make it interesting
develop on Android, or particularly interesting.
>> HINDMAN: One of the things that our team
really likes is the Monkey Tool, that it allows
him to kind of do some emulation and it’s
really pseudo-random events that are generated
by the tool that allows them to go ahead and,
you know, use it the way users are using it.
The way a user will kind of fumble with it
and poke buttons and push things here and
there. That’s what the Monkey Tool does.
So that it, you know, has system-level events
like that and then user-generated events,
and it does a random stream of that. And then
it will do one that’s a little bit different
that’s a random stream and it shows you
how users would really interact with it, and
it’s really helpful on the development cycle.
>> That’s great. Are there particular things
about the Android platform because it’s
open that you can do with your application
that you might not be able to do on other
platforms?
>> HINDMAN: Yeah, there’s a couple of things.
The virtual key pad or key board that allows
you to kind of touch the search box in our
applications and then it just boom!, it just
kind of pops right up there, is really new
to us and it enables some functionality that
we’re just kind of now thinking through
how are we going to take advantage of it,
and also, the painting over video. The fact
that that keyboard will pop up even when the
video is playing in the background allows
us to do some kind of text-based stuff that
is really cool. So, you can still type, you
know, over that video while it’s playing.
The keyboard goes back down, the video continues
to play. And so it just--it makes the device
or the application more rich and allows us
to do things we couldn’t otherwise do.
>> Well, it’s great. Well, thank you for
taking the time to talk to us today. I look
forward to exploring the application.
>> HINDMAN: My pleasure.
>> All right.
>> HINDMAN: Thank you.
>> Thanks.
>> HINDMAN: All right.